we're seeing election interference from
Big Tech already
and it's not Trump getting kicked off
Twitter and it's not DeSantis getting
kicked off YouTube or something it is my
friend
the vague ramaswamy being kicked off of
LinkedIn which is I have to say the most
Vivek social network to be kicked off of
that is so I've mentioned that uh the
fake and I know each other from college
I was an undergraduate when he was at
the law school we were in similar kind
of clubs and organizations to to one
another
um and and so at the time we we didn't
know each other very well during college
but he had a reputation as being just
very type a very meticulous very very
intelligent very serious and ambitious
and successful and he obviously has
proven that he sold a company for a ton
of money he uh attended the top Law
School in the country at least when he
was there it seems to have gone downhill
since then and now he's running for
president he's a best-selling author you
know very impressive guy I just love the
idea that for Vivek his kind of Doom
scrolling you know in his free time is
that he's just on LinkedIn and this is
very professional responsible social
media app and he was kicked off Legend
delay for spreading misinformation
here's why he was kicked off I was a bit
surprised to get an email noting that my
LinkedIn account had been shut down I
wondered why because Alexa the number of
friends texted me saying they followed
me on LinkedIn that's how they keep up
they weren't able to find me anymore and
so when I had my team get in touch with
LinkedIn here's the response that we got
I'm not kidding I'm reading from this
apparently my third strike was to say
this the climate agenda is a lie fossil
fuels are a requirement for human
prosperity
those are my three strikes that got me
censored on LinkedIn
now it's it's kind of funny and
LinkedIn doesn't matter obviously as
much as Twitter or
Google or YouTube or or Facebook though
LinkedIn is owned by Microsoft so we're
talking about a very big company and it
shows you okay they think they can go
after Vivek right now because he doesn't
have as much name recognition and and so
it they'll get less pushback than if
they went after Trump or DeSantis and
okay it's just this one
think about how early we are in the race
though and already you're seeing these
kinds of shenanigans to me
LinkedIn going after Vivek this way is a
little warning shot it's a little test
shot in the race to see what happens now
we have new candidates in the race
Mike Pence has long been rumored to be
interested in entering the race
Pence has not said that he's running
but he kind of got scooped by CNN here
in that CNN released word that that he
is going to participate in a CNN
presidential Town Hall
a little awkward said that they made
that announcement before he announced
that he's running for president
presumably though if you participate in
a CNN Town Hall you are running for
president
and uh Mike Pence has gone now on other
networks and he's started to begin the
process of crafting a message for his
campaign
here is Mike Pence going after Ron
DeSantis on Fox Business
I just don't believe it's it's in the
interest of the people of any state for
a a government to essentially go after a
business that they disagreed with on a
political issue I disagree with Florida
moving against uh Walt Disney I disagree
with California moving against Walgreens
because they're going to obey the law
about a board of patience in some 20
States so they're going to cancel 120
million dollar project look at the end
of the day the business of America is
business and and I'm not terribly
surprised to see Disney canceling a
billion dollar contract it's on that's
only going to harm people in the Orlando
and Florida area and and it's one more
reason why uh well as a limited
government conservative uh I've said for
months now that I I think both sides
ought to stand down take the victory for
parents rights in the legislature and
move on right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles do you remember the last time
you had a free phone starting not
feeling great right and then came the
Hefty activation fees the four line
requirements and of course that binding
contract Pure Talk is giving you a free
5G Samsung Galaxy phone without the
feeling that you've been duped when you
switch to Pure talks unlimited talk and
text data plan that comes with a mobile
hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung Galaxy
for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price of
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile here's another
thing you'll be on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network how do I know
because I am a customer make the switch
to Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company and I'm proud to stand behind
because one they have a great service
and two they're proud to stand behind
our mission at the daily wire pure talks
us-based customer service team will help
you make the switch in as little as 10
minutes and you can even keep your phone
number go to puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans buy
Americans
so this message is probably not going to
resonate with a lot of people at least
not right now the GOP base seems to be
pretty eager for
an aggressive response to the cultural
war that the libs have been waging
especially when we're talking about
Disney down in Florida or Bud Light or
Target or any of these other companies
and Mike Pence is offering a
fairly contrarian argument here he's
saying look the business of America is
business that's a line from Calvin
Coolidge it's in the business of
America's business we don't really want
to antagonize business too much we we
want to be social conservatives we want
to defend our values but we don't want
to just Pummel these businesses into the
ground you know and and Ronda Santos he
went too far here this is a message that
to some degree is is being put forward
by President Trump the difference is
that Trump is such a belligerent
cultural figure that he he
somewhat probably uniquely can make both
of those arguments at the same time out
of the one side of his mouth he can say
Mexicans are rapists and murderers and
we've got to deport everybody and then
out of the other side he can say all
right we need to make a deal and bring
the temperature down a little bit and
the other candidates are falling down on
one side or the other so DeSantis is
falling down very much on the we're
going to Pummel Disney into the ground
side of things and Mike Pence here is
trying to carve out a new space for
himself in the race and he's saying look
I'm the pro-business guy I'm the Calvin
Coolidge Republican I am the return to
normalcy that's his argument and it's a
little bit of a long shot argument right
now just judging from where the GOP base
is but I think it's not the craziest
idea for a campaign in that you've got
Trump running As Trump
you've got DeSantis running As Trump 2.0
so they're both running in the Trump
Lane which is it which is a kind of old
right
anti-globalism to some degree anti-free
trade Pat Buchanan kind of right wing
then you've got Vivek he's the outsider
candidate then you've got Nikki Haley
and Tim Scott they're running a little
bit more of a Centrist moderate campaign
and Mike Pence is going to run on a
return to normalcy people are going to
mock it he's not doing great in the
polls right now Joe Biden however ran
the return to normalcy campaign and the
return to normalcy campaign worked out
relatively well for him along with the
institutional advantages that the
Democrats had what a great clip I'm so
glad you liked it make sure you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel ring that Bell we'll see you
next time